let me get to them one competitive
sports
they are not of god
they're contrary to the spirit of christ
christ's spirit is i lose so you can win
that's calvary
i lose
for your sakes he became poor that ye
through his poverty might become rich
competitive sport says i will do
everything i can to stop you from
scoring one goal
i will slam you to the boards in ice
hockey i will break your legs in
football i will look undercut you in
basketball i will whatever
competitive sports are not of god
i'm upsetting those of you who worship
arsenal manchester united competitive
sports are not of god this is the
houston astros or whatever they are not
of god are you with me recreation is of
god
difference i remember many years ago i
was in the house of a friend of mine and
he had a table tennis in the basement so
he and i were just hitting the ball he
said let's play a game i said why
come on let's play why let's hit the
ball come on let's play a game so we
played i beat him 21.5
that was the end of his desire to play a
game he wanted someone to win or lose
this is not the spirit of god
you see it on pick up games on the
playgrounds someone fouled and i didn't
foul you fouled he looked like a foul
you fouled him
no not me they put their hands up lying
lying
competitive sports are not of god what
was the other one